not in his usual presidential attire on
this mobile phone video the 83 year old
president appears disheveled he's being
detained by the country's special forces
men meant to protect him now hold him in
custody one soldier asks him have you
been beaten or injured no he says
on national television cool leader
mamadi dumbuya a former french
legionnaire now head of the country's
special forces says the borders are
closed and the constitution dissolved
conde has been deposed
the personalization of politics of
political life is over we will no longer
entrust politics to a man we will
entrust it to the people we come only
for that it is the duty of a soldier to
save the country the only thing that
motivates us is that we are going to put
in place a system that does not exist
and we must all build this system
together
there were celebrations in some
neighborhoods of the capital before an
overnight nationwide curfew was put in
place with the military patrolling the
streets cool leaders have removed
regional governors and replaced them
with military commanders the military
has asked civil servants to return to
work on monday and all former ministers
and government officials are expected to
gather at 11 am at the people's palace
the coup leaders say any defiance will
be treated as an act of rebellion
earlier gunfire and explosions were
heard around the presidential palace
with men in uniform asking residents to
stay indoors
alpha conde won last october's
presidential election amidst widespread
protest he amended the constitution
allowing him to run for a third mandate
the outcome was disputed by the
opposition and members of civil society
[Applause]
security forces fired live rounds to
disperse the demonstrators
french president macomb accused conde of
grabbing power with neighboring senegal
and guinea-bissau closing their borders
leaving the president increasingly
isolated
has been accused by critics of
corruption and profiting from the
mineral-rich country while leaving the
citizens in poverty last week alfa conde
asked the parliament to raise the budget
for the president while reducing budgets
and wages of the civil servants and
members of the security forces during
further discontent especially among the
ranks of the armed forces clearly
the
security forces they are divided as this
has been pointed out but we are the one
leading the game right now
and uh
some people are wondering if they are
somewhat political leader in the
background it's too early to say that
the united nations secretary general has
called for the immediate release of the
president and condemned the takeover by
security forces the african union and
ecowas have also condemned the coup with
a west african bloc threatening
sanctions if the elected government
isn't reinstated after 11 years in power
and thwarting numerous coup attempts
alphaconde appears meek
and humiliated no longer in power in a
country in chaos faced with uncertainty
nicholas hawk al jazeera
well ghanaian journalist youssef barr
sent us this update from conakry
up till now the president is in the hand
of the special force
um they've confirmed it and they said
the president is safe and nothing's
going to happen with the president
and they've asked all unions to go to
work tomorrow
and they've asked all government
authorities to refer to more at the
parliament building anybody who refused
to go you will take that person they'll
call that president a rebel and this
person first will be arrested
and just now military officials we are
telling us talking to weebly journalists
around the national television tonight
although we have the coffee
they said to all you so this school is
not a military coup this is for the
people we are here to free the people we
are here the people of guinea have been
suffering so they're asking all unions
to support that he said it's
they are getting the support from the
general public
everybody is in line with the uh cool
leaders everybody up to now already is
coffee but there are some areas to go in
the streets still dancing welcoming the
military and there is no military patrol
in the streets nobody's patrolling the
streets they've asked everybody to go to
work tomorrow so if people go to work
tomorrow definitely hundred percent the
military have succeeded everybody's in
support of them they came a time when
guineans
were asking for change
most of the genius we're asking for
change so this is exactly what is
happening
well the u.n secretary general has
tweeted about the coup in guinea saying
i'm personally following this situation
there very closely i strongly condem any
takeover of the government by force of
the gun and call for the immediate
release of president alfa conde
aquacioce is a professor of history and
political science at delaware university
he says citizens are backing colonel
dambuya
don't forget kendall dumboya is a kandy
man
he was placed in charge of the special
forces and specially trained to protect
khan day
so i think it's important to understand
why perhaps the country
seems to stand behind him because he is
considered a conde person and if he
believes that this is what they need to
do then perhaps
that's why they're following him so all
sources say that in spite of the au
equals
requests
for them to go back to the barracks uh
it's not working it's not being heard in
guinea and the people are behind canal
dambuya we just have to look next door
to mali to find out what happened in
mali and could evolve for for example
we're talking about situations where uh
sitting presidents forced their way into
uh
unconstitutional uh third terms
and we know what happened in mali we
still have the military in control
they're still discussing
what to do next in mali i believe that
is precisely what's going to happen in
guinea um it's you know right now
there's no question that
um
uh
keno dambuya is in charge and he's the
de facto head so sanctions or no
sanctions they they would have to talk
to him
and more importantly they would have to
take the measure of the country and it
is clear that it is a popular uprising
at least as of the moment